estábamos viendo una las proyecciones no
de los votos un una tendencia digamos
con receta Jeep erdoan claramente
llevándole la delantera al líder
opositor de mantenerse esta tendencia
que se puede esperar para el futuro de
Turquía
Bueno pues desde luego la campaña
electoral se ha basado en ese occidente
u oriente es decir Turquía mirando con
erdogan hacia oriente o con click aroglu
hacia occidente Y eso ha marcado a
polarizado mucho la situación y el voto
y bueno también no deja de ser llamativo
lo que ha acontecido Precisamente en el
mes anterior a las elecciones con la
reunión con Rusia con china con Irán al
respecto de Siria de la resolución del
conflicto en Siria y de cómo tanto click
como erdogan tratado sobre la cuestión
por el lado de clic dar óvulo lo
trataban como que en el plazo de un año
si él salía elegido expulsarían a todos
los refugiados sirios de vuelta a Siria
pero en el caso de erdogan eso incluía
primero un acuerdo de paz una
estabilización de Siria y por el otro
lado la resolución de la cuestión kurda
con el PK y bueno En definitiva la
terminación finalmente de la operación
turca de la ocupación turca de
territorios del norte de Siria y bueno
En definitiva la resolución Al fin y al
cabo de un conflicto de más de 12 años
que llevan la región entonces ahí está
esa cuestión interna externa Oriente
occidente y también la importancia
estratégica del sur de qué va a ser de
Siria Y de qué va a ser de todos los
millones de refugiados sirios que siguen
todavía en Siria temas claves Que
estaremos abordando a lo largo de esta
cobertura especial ahora es la primera
vez que recete allí erdoan asiste a una
segunda vuelta bueno que el país asiste
digamos a un balotas O sea no la tuvo
tan fácil como en otras elecciones no
obstante el resultado termina
favoreciendo lo A qué atribuye tanto esa
dificultad como este resultado
sí la dificultad se puede atribuir
básicamente a la cuestión económica la
inflación tan
descomunal de Turquía una situación
económica En definitiva interna del país
muy compleja pero claro erdogan se ha
buscado las cartas estratégicas en el
exterior Tratando de buscar de encontrar
ese voto nacionalista de Turquía y
llevándoselo a su terreno porque bueno
no deja de tener no hay que tener en
cuenta que durante el último año por
ejemplo todos los todas las presiones
hacia Grecia la campaña también de
amenazas contra Grecia por un lado la
presión hacia Armenia en Favor de hacer
vayan por otro y la cuestión de Siria
por otro así como Libia Asia central el
mundo
panturquico o panturano como cada uno lo
prefiera llamar y En definitiva bueno
erdogan ha buscado que esa carta
internacional tenga más peso que la
carta interna y sobre todo que esa carta
internacional mirando entre comillas
hacia Oriente es decir No mirando hacia
occidente sino hacia Oriente tenga una
proyección a futuro mucho mayor que
respecto a un occidente que por otro
lado les ha dejado durante 24 años en el
caso de la Unión Europea como candidato
a la Unión Europea desde 1999 y no se ha
visto al efecto mientras que eso lo han
utilizado muchos sectores en Turquía
para decir Oigan es que a Ucrania le
quieren dar paso libre rápido para
meterlos en la Unión Europea o incluso
haciendo un modus un modo concreto para
ellos pero a nosotros nos han tenido
desde 1999 y nos siguen exigiendo cosas
pero sin visos de que vamos a ser parte
de la Unión Europea Entonces en este
sentido bueno erdogan trabajo esa mirada
hacia Oriente hacia lo que no es
occidente y bueno esa carta
internacional ha tenido un grandísimo
valor
en la campaña electoral Pero bueno En
definitiva Sí para muchos analistas o
militares o políticos pues desde luego
pero claro el ciudadano de a pie y por
eso se ha llegado a la segunda vuelta ve
su cartera de su economía personal de
sus proyecciones de trabajo en Turquía
dice Bueno la situación internacional
bien promete mucho pero la interna
también es muy muy compleja